[Music]
in right way of news submitted by oh I
read it wrong in right of way when two
cars come together and a intersection
together guess who goes first the one on
your right the right of way the right of
way submitted by last name stock a
police officer hit a cyclist while
making a turn and then gave him a ticket
that's right that's what happens when
people get embarrassed when they do
wrong yeah and they just had to try to
cover it up if I was a police officer I
would just hit everybody and get
everybody tickets was the bicycle person
having a camera is that why they want no
yeah what is the thing one who won we
don't you and I chose my TV it's
actually the rabbi I thought he was no
so what happened yeah so what happened
here is I would just show you a video
[Music]
let's see shut up already TIFF quick
this is the cop oh wait where was what
you said this was a cop and he hit so
this is somebody else look across the
street is where it happens somebody
else's dashcam
oh he wrecked don't hop [ __ ] up yeah
he looked Gandhi well unless it was a
red stop well you know what it was this
looks like a right turns it's green boy
doesn't matter if it's green it's still
there's still a light that it'll tell
you to walk or to stop so that doesn't
matter that it's yes oh I see Bobby I'm
just saying chances are when it's a
green it's probable I thought also too
if you're going to use the crosswalk if
you're on a bike you I have to get off
and you have to walk your bike there's
that law too
there's a lot but you also the
pedestrian always hasn't right away but
he's not a petition cuz he's on a bike
yeah
now this is semantics because the walk
and stop only applies for pedestrians
not bicycles I vote to get the CI
involved yeah he was riding on the wrong
side of the street then because the
traffic was going this way was going
this way that's okay
nobody wasn't either the cop was making
a right turn I can't tell he was making
a right turn okay so the cop was making
a right turn and it was out of red light
we could tell we go back :
see that's a your the black the black
God remember you don't see thank you to
you I got LASIK
I got LASIK I could see through it you
know the final who's right or wrong well
they're both in the wrong don't tell me
I just want to know yes or no question
and I answered no you told me that that
you gave me more information you didn't
answer yes or no because I wanted to go
around the room and see what everyone
thought let's just recreate this get
your car I asked you do you know it Jess
or no you didn't answer yes or no do you
have a cat an eagle I have two cats you
didn't say yes or no you can at first
you can think this is a yes-or-no
question that's what do you imply I'll
be quiet
I knew their place in Virginia nice
that's how they're wrong not vagina
because they were both cousins they
[ __ ] each other this officer he was
turning and here we sit because they
[ __ ] each other and they all work for
the tobacco factory I have no teeth he
had to kill his sister cousin okay so
the officer was turning right at a red
light
yep where the officer [ __ ] up this is
where he was in the wrong is the fact
that he was covered he was already
covering the entire yield before that
yeah as team you just went like you've
even look to be both ways that's called
a California roll yeah he did a
California roll
Virginia so then the cyclists were he
[ __ ] up is that there was that orange
hand on the pedestrian red the redhead
tip it's a redhead I'm going off of the
art of this article saying orient the
articles maybe the lens in Virginia Oh
true thank you master tobacco plant what
they do
it does look written I would do it looks
read anyway you see no I don't know I
can't see there so I don't know Newt you
were colored how do you know what color
that is
I can see it have you seen the one
that's like specifically a bicycle and
it's like no like I like the ones in
Japan where it starts walking slowly and
then it's like hurry the [ __ ] up and you
got a run japanses on next hole where
the cyclist [ __ ] up is that
obviously he shouldn't have gone red
yeah so they are saying that it wasn't
illegal that he was on the crosswalk
sidewalk it was gonna be legal he did
that the crosswalk on the bike that's
okay that's what they're saying and and
so yeah and then it's fine that he was
riding against traffic what that's not
OK here though well the crosswalk is
both ways though it rarely is riding
against traffic he's crossing the street
right because traffic's going this way
he's going this way I understand okay
yeah cuz if you're on a bike you're
consign oh you can't do that here is a
vehicle you can't ride your bike across
traffic yeah you can't even be on this
side it says that it's not advisable but
it's also not illegal in Virginia yeah
so what was the ticket for oh because of
the fact that he went when he shouldn't
have gone oh like he was actually taken
to the hospital for minor injuries but
then right after his when he got this
ticket so yeah we can happen try it
happened to me luckily I didn't knocked
a person off the bike but I did clip
them for the same name so but no I crept
up and then like I hit the back tire and
he was like whoa dude that's just hella
fun isn't it so he's gonna give him the
ticket and now the bicyclist would be
like hello police officer here's a
lawsuit Oh that'd be bosses [ __ ] that's
what I would do
they were both wrong though so I don't
know if it would well I'd assume just to
be a [ __ ] and so I would sue him for
the amount of the ticket plus one dollar
Oh
you patty well you should have been like
I [ __ ] up and I look like I [ __ ] up
- are you ok are you ok good see you
later
but that police officer is now gonna get
[ __ ] yeah cuz he's ahead he - he was
like like I just ran this dude over I'm
gonna give you a take I wouldn't even do
that I was like dude you already got
your [ __ ] punishment you're on the
floor on the concrete you piece of [ __ ]
now get out I'd have been like let me
take you to the hospital okay it's all
caught on film yeah they're both wrong
take him to the hospital you probably
thought he was that right though like he
doesn't give a [ __ ] he's on film he's
like yeah they [ __ ] up I want to have
a body cam on me at all times now this
is that meant from the police department
says as you can see in this video the
officer was stopped at a traffic light
waiting to make a right turn into
southbound Richmond Highway from the
Mount Vernon Plaza shopping center the
cyclist was writing northbound on the
sidewalk of the southbound side of
Richmond Highway he entered Fordson Road
from the sidewalk without stopping and
disregarded the pedestrian signal our
event and our investigation shows the
officer had the right-of-way and
determined it was safe to enter the
intersection when the cyclist came off
the sidewalk and hit the cruiser but
then the people that are writing this
article they're like oh yeah he's trying
to been covering the entire sidewalk
anyway or a crosswalk that's not okay
the fact that he inched forward well
they're gonna back him up of course and
like he didn't look both ways yeah I
mean like that's why a judge needs to
rule on it not say we we have an
internal investigation and we think it's
great there's cameras isn't it crazy now
like with cameras cops just cannot we
can't get away yeah the guy needs to get
out way with goddess's to say such
racist things test asian people we're
doing like the you know like the whole
gang banging phase oh god I got call
[ __ ] so much and I was a DB little
asian kid I wasn't even gangbanger I got
called the FA ggot word although all the
time all the time yeah yeah we used to
play this thing called night tag at the
school campus because I learned that for
my brother and his friends and so like
if you go so we didn't know that if you
got into the suit that the teachers
lounge it triggers a silent alarm
and so like cops came and the first
thing they said was get on the floor
[ __ ] like why would you say that to me
and I was not gay so I didn't want to go
on the floor so I don't know who use
time and what the sexual
orientation has anything to do with
crying I know how dare you I think that
was just like the hot word that was the
hot installable mm is that and like
mother [ __ ] was like ancestral or
homosexual yeah so mean wait so then why
is it illegal for you to call them names
then they could call you names
because they have a gun yeah it's it's
not illegal for us to call them names no
you can see what everyone they give you
[ __ ] for it but it's not only you can't
get in trouble or like don't they say
you could flip off cops
that's obvious yeah but then wouldn't
they say that I've never seen white
people talk to cops they're straight
jelly I can call all kinds of [ __ ]
names yeah they have the biggest balls
when there's cops around white people
are fearless when they talk to cops
yeah it is an interesting phenomena I've
never seen her interact with police but
then I don't know it's just she's
fearless in general when she talks to
people I think it's just also taught to
fear law enforcement yeah but I feel
like in the in like in like a white
commute there taught that they work for
you
the other way around because I was too
clear you're a public servant exactly
for me they're my [ __ ] watchdog yeah
there's like oh [ __ ] man they're gonna
pull me they're gonna put me on a curb
they're gonna ask them they're gonna
waste my time for two hours straight I'm
gonna sit down on the curb I'm even near
a carving it's so [ __ ] nervous I
don't know what happens but every time a
cop tries to pull me over I somehow end
up in a two-piece suit hello are you all
of a sudden you act like you belong in a
Ritz Carlton yeah oh hello I had a
mohawk for a little bit for a show that
I did and for the three months that had
that mohawk I got pulled over probably
twice two three times a week it's not
like you're a punk of yeah are you
driving I have a Hyundai Elantra how
dare they that's a very economical car
yeah they're like pull over and there
was always the same question have you
been drinking today and I was like maybe
we could suck at driving have you been
party yeah well you must be dreaming
with that [ __ ] mohawk poor choices
yeah I was like oh I wish I was
but I was always like you know never
know New York knows in LA and New York
is different New York is like more like
like post 9/11 airport security but like
the police up because police officers
they're very everyone's mixed and
there's like you just seen like culture
everywhere yeah just different races
everywhere all right they'll be like a
Chinese store across to the next to an
Indian store and there'll be like 50
Mexicans down the street you know doing
their own thing and then the Russians
will be on the other side of the block
you have every type of Latino community
Amin LA is diverse but it's just
recently that the police force has
become diverse so when we're all growing
up like you every single minority
neighborhood still had all white cops
yeah that's probably why that racial
tension and whatever yeah I would say
it's getting better now but yeah I just
though the Asian cops were the meanest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]